pop quiz hotshot you've got 48
milliseconds of work to do but only 16
milliseconds per frame to get it done
what do you do my name is Colt McAnlis
and while threading on Android can help
cure your performance woes it can also
end up creating some huge problems if
you don't understand how it's all
working under the hood so let's take a
few minutes and make sure we're all on
the same page see a thread by default
does three things it starts it does some
works and as soon as that work is done
it terminates now by itself that's not
too useful instead what you want is a
thread that sticks around for a while so
you can feed it packets of work to
operate on but to do that you need a
little more scaffolding first since
threads die when they run out of work
you need to have some sort of loop
running on the thread to keep it alive
just make sure to put it in exit
condition so you can terminate that loop
later in addition you'll need some sort
of queue that the loop can pull blocks
of work from to execute on and of course
you'll need some other thread that
creates work packets and pushes them
into the queue for execution now if
you've ever tried to write this setup
yourself you know it gets a little
gnarly to get all of that machinery
working correctly thankfully though
Android has a set of classes to do all
that for you
for example the looper class will keep
the thread alive and pop work off a
queue to execute on and rather than
always inserting work at the end of that
queue the handler class gives you the
control to push work at the head the
tail or a set a time-based delay that
will keep some work from being processed
until that time has passed
and don't forget the units of work in
Android you are explicitly defined as
intense or runnable Zoar messages
depending on who's issuing them and
who's consuming them and then the
combination of all these things together
is called a handler thread which lets
this look like this pretty nifty huh so
let's look at how you can use this in
your application when the user launches
your app Android creates its own Linux
process alongside with this the system
creates a thread of execution for your
application called the main thread which
at its core is just a handler thread
this main thread handles processing of
events from all over your app for
example callbacks associated with
lifecycle information or callbacks from
input events or even events that are
coming from other applications and
most important is that these callbacks
can trigger other work that runs on
their thread - like making a change to
the UI will create work packets that
allow the UI to be redrawn basically
this means that any block of code your
app wants to run has to be pushed into a
work queue and then serviced on the main
thread the takeaway here is that with so
much work happening on the main thread
it makes a lot of sense to offload
longer work to other threads as to not
disturb the UI system from its rendering
duties and this is how the entirety of
androids threading model works now lots
of packages of work being passed around
between threads and worked on as needed
so with all this in mind some of
androids threading classes make a little
bit more sense see each threaded class
is intended for a specific type of
threading work so picking the right one
for your needs is really important for
example the async task class is ideal
for helping you get work on and off the
UI thread in the right way handler
threads are great when you need a
dedicated thread for callbacks to land
on and thread pools work best when you
can break your work up into really small
packets and then toss them to a bunch of
waiting threads and intent services are
really ideal for background tasks or
when you need to get intent work off the
UI thread and like everything else
there's not a silver bullet here but
knowing which primitive is best for what
situation can save you a lot of
headaches now if you ever want more
insight into how your app is leveraging
threading make sure you spend some time
getting comfortable with systrace it's a
fancy tool that will school you on how
about that mumbo-jumbo is working
underneath the hood and if you're
looking to get schooled more make sure
you check out the rest of the Android
performance patterns videos and don't
forget to join our Google+ community for
more tips and tricks on threading so
keep calm profile your code and always
remember perf matters